let's go to david from scotland david
you're on the air
hello david how are you how are you i'm
i'm excellent can i
start by just thanking kyoko from japan
for such an amazingly
positive representation of your
international audience what a lovely
person she was
you would nothing short of a perfect
phone call right lovely perfect lovely
yeah anyone asks always perfect and i
would like to ask your thoughts
as an immigrant if you don't mind me
asking
about how cultures can interact
yes um in scotland we have a lot of
americans
who come over here to research their
roots
and we love it we really really want
to engage with the world anyone that
wants to come over here we're happy to
have you
beautiful however i've noticed that a
lot of americans that do come over here
are slightly jarred by our politics a
lot of them are surprised by
um how in their words socialistic we are
oh see so here's the thing this would be
in any country in
any country um there are so many
clueless americans it's very common that
americans show up somewhere and they
have no idea what's going on and they
look
shocked that's that's not unique to
scotland
yes yes i entirely agree with you
except that the genus of these tourists
are that they are incredibly well
involved they're
incredibly well educated they know
documentary history they know scott's
law
that they can rely on to do their
research they know where they want to go
they know who they want to talk to like
often these people
are um well for one wealthy enough to be
able to come to scotland
but also come to scotland with an intent
behind it
i see what surprises me
is that when they do they've done all
this research
other than they've never researched how
scotland will see them
right well that is very american
to say i'm gonna go wherever and i don't
care how they see me
you should see the things i've seen in
france my friend
i i remember um a few years ago i was
in washington dc i met a few americans
an event for
scots abroad yeah and i used to smoke at
the time
i pulled out a cigarette packet from
europe
that i don't know if you know this but
in europe all of our cigarette packets
have warnings on them
yes same in the u.s
yeah but like very graphic warnings yeah
right right the pic you have like
pictures of black tongues and stuff
there
yeah like like the whole shebang like
please don't smoke all that stuff
yeah i've since given up smoking but at
the time i pulled out this packet and
somebody made a comment to me
like like in in this event
that i didn't know y'all were that nazi
over that's weird yeah that's i mean i'd
have to talk to that person but that
sounds
odd for sure for sure the the the point
i'm trying to get to
is it took me a year to try to
just like um break down that
conversation in my head
and that was just one conversation how
many
cultural barriers are we
[Music]
hello
hello uh sorry sorry i i lost you there
for a second
how many cultural barriers are we not
even discussing
that we just take for granted i think
many i think many
many many many david
thank you very much for your thoughts
hey listen david before you go what do
you
what do you call the category of drinks
that includes coca-cola sprite fanta etc
uh for us it's just like well it depends
if you're on the west coast of scotland
you call it jeg
[Music]
[Music]
east coast of scotland we would just
call it like just
hello we would just call it juice
on the east coast you would call it just
just like the spanish word for juice
yes but that's a joke by the way i'm not
that's it's hugo i know that
spell spell it one more time for me at j
u i c e juice g
u i c e j you oh juice
juice like here okay you call soda juice
okay and then what do you call what do
you call juice
what we call it just so how do you
distinguish soda versus juice
uh well we do it through interpretive
dance no um
we just like a lot of scots is built on
intonation and tone rather than the
words that you say
so it's like oh can i get a jeg as
opposed to oh can i get a jig
those mean different things really and
one means juice and one means soda
yeah that is shocking
so that is shocking okay all right david
i'm gonna i'm gonna
you know chew on that a bit i appreciate
the call and thank you very much for
putting up with my bad signal
my my pleasure all right there we go
david from scotland wow
one of our sponsors purevpn is giving
you 47
off a one-year plan which comes out to
less than six bucks a month
purevpn makes you anonymous online and
you can trust them they're the only vpn
with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity is not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week
for just 99 cents and you'll get 47
percent off a one-year plan
which is less than six bucks a month
when you go to davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman